always always gundam with the the hard
hitting music
so good um welcome everybody i'm live on
twitch right now but i will be putting
this video
up on youtube after i play the first
hour we are playing sd gundam battle
alliance today thank you to gun of the
sponsoring the stream i'm a very big
gundam fan i've been building gundam
since i was
i don't know 12 13.
um and so when they were like hey wanna
play it i was like glad you asked was
going to anyway
[Laughter]
so if you don't know anything about this
game it's um
a multiplayer gun imagine rpg you get to
play super deformed which is what the sd
stands for an sd gun and battle alliance
uh gundams
and i'm gonna be playing solo today but
you can play with friends um
in the
mech combat and it's gonna be my first
hour to be the first that i've seen of
it
so i'm excited to check it out
uh
thank you shouldn't be shrink
and um
yeah if you're watching on twitch you
put in the command gundam and it'll give
you a link to where you can check out
the game
um and on youtube it should be in the
description so yeah use my link to check
out sc gundam battle alliance
let's have fun playing through the first
hour here today
some of these are really fun because it
means i get to play
games on time like this might have been
something that would have taken me a few
weeks otherwise but
i'm excited to play it today let's do it
again have not even pressed start yet
this is just me opening it up but i do
know a little bit about this game
uh where some of the games that i do
first hours of i don't know anything
about so
a little bit more well-informed
the system start configuration loading
the simulator system
story play takes place in g universe
it's um basically this world where
gundam cannon is like shifted and
different which is very cool
it's like a distorted history basically
even this is cool
just so extra
maybe i should move my camera a little
bit
welcome to g universe it says that i'm
currently busy
the earth federation forces commenced
operation odessa a certain special
forces support squadron took part in the
eye they gather combat data for the gm
alias
gatherer
squadron
and
commander
me too bestie
this looks very nostalgic thus far i
feel like this looks
a like of the games i was playing in the
early 2000s
all right
very dramatic opening my my mind
um
yes so it's like an alternate universe
you play as a three-unit squadron
consisting of mobile suits
and it has pilots from across gundam
history because uh it being
alternate universe kind of means it can
function that way
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
this is the cutest thing i've ever seen
[Music]
okay
select a response
questions we're gonna go with the
questions
[Music]
[Music]
oh thank you for the raid jacob
yes gundam game uh just came out this is
andy gunn sd sorry gundam battle
alliance it's actually three player
jacob um
if you want to play it let me know
i just chose to play solo because you
can but yeah it is also fully uh
multiplayer um
and it's basically just like a big old
action
rpg bunch of different weapons
different mobile suits
all that good stuff supposedly very easy
to play it's supposed to be pretty easy
to get into as well
they call it um a deep single player but
casual called multiplayer which is cool
thank you thor strike
and jpat 1993 good year good year good
year
[Music]
okay
[Music]
it's gonna be okay owen
as always
[Music]
because it's no i'm gonna um like should
i do charolana's for this one
because it's big on multiplayer
[Music]
um yeah i don't believe the game has uh
has micro transactions um i don't
believe it does i think i asked about
that
[Music]
let's go
thank you tren
[Music]
registration complete rank and sign up
federation forces commander of the
special team known as the independent
mechanized hybrid technical support
squadron aka the gathering squadron
i see you're the chosen one this time
bye-bye commando we'll meet again
[Music]
only thing is that his micro is the
gundams
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
i only just started playing spanking a
monkey um but i did check out
impressions of it and people really like
it
seem to really like it which i guess is
the intended audience
i think somebody said um
it could be pretty grindy but that the
gameplay is fun so
those aspects are you know
downstairs he's not with me right now
all right let's roll oh my god
this is very cute
[Music]
so excited for this game been waiting a
bit yes so i suspect that again uh this
game is going to appeal to gundam fans i
have no idea people who aren't gunner
fans are going to like it
um
but i know that the kind of community's
been pretty excited about it for a long
time myself
blind should lock onto the zaku while
locked on the screen centers on the
target cancel lock on the queue okay
beautiful
attack the enemy with wheelie equipment
there are two types of melee attacks
normal and special
okay
okay how do i do special milling c
okay okay okay
all right i'm ready let's go
i can dance all day i can dance all day
try and hit me try and hit me
if you toss an enemy into the air with a
launching attack you can keep the
pressure on with the combo okay cool
he's launching attack
[Music]
oh am i not locked on
fully messed up
this is one of my favorite songs in the
entire franchise by the way
[Music]
[Music]
such a good song dude
[Music]
and it plays in so many episodes of the
show and like it's every like cool fight
it's such a good song it was really
annoyed that it's not on spotify
hello
[Music]
all right all right all right
i should probably slow down a tiny bit
hey bail fire
and trim
[Music]
not
if this song plays this whole game i'll
be
[Music]
stoked you can use a repair kit to heal
and ms is hp
[Music]
there you go you just gotta be a little
bit closer
that's dead
there's somebody up right yeah
[Music]
so this is definitely very simple
um
which to me means successfully which is
always good
you might know the gifted sub trim i
appreciate that and old sam thank you
page money these are awesome headphones
yes i love them
hello because evan how you doing
i feel like i haven't seen you in a
minute
is
they should make a lego gundam that
would be cool
chain breakers chain breakers consume
half a skill meter okay
speedy loading screens let's go
well not the setting the the just the
premise
it's a fun one
multiplayer
foreign
[Music]
tanks
and i see you can hit with one though
that is very helpful
foreign
out of my face
[Music]
if there's um oh i can't
pause oh that's not good
i'm not sure how to change one
what if i want to try sub one or sub two
two
three
no
[Music]
not sure
should probably try and figure that out
[Music]
it's a good ui actually
i want to do another
it's like when you're trying to catch a
legendary pokemon and you accidentally
killed him
yeah
that is cool
it seems to do the most damage as well
that's sick
oh i've not been guarding at all
i wonder if maybe i should heal soon
i feel like i'm okay for a while
[Applause]
no
i hate strong heat sources
the voice acting is good tony doctor
that is not an mmo no it is a
three-player action rpg
ooh okay yeah
he's always a big boy in um
evolution which i was also playing
recently i mean i will play pretty much
everything
he's definitely one of the hardest
thank you jessie jane and jojo
against him oh i wasn't guarding that
time
so much range man
oh my god he's so cute though i'd love
to build a chibi gun that looks like
that
i've seen the rx 78 one which is very
cute
and there's like a hello kitty one as
well
[Music]
okay thank god he was slow enough
the god is great
[Music]
or is he down
special attack a powerful attack you can
activate by using the spa gauge
vnf okay
okay
okay
[Laughter]
let's go baby
it's all right we'll take it
i just can't get him aerial
[Music]
um i don't know what that is because
edmund i'm sorry i don't know how to
help you with that because i don't
actually know what that is
thank
that was pretty challenging i wonder how
much it scales again they did say that
it was supposed to be like accessible
pretty easy for everyone to pick up so
i'm not expecting it to be super
challenging
i didn't pick up anything
[Music]
the breakout was successful welcome to
our headquarters
hold on where's the rescue squad have
you seen them commander i haven't yeah i
wonder what happens when you play this
part
with three plays i guess you probably
all just go through the same thing solar
right
one day i'll stop dancing on streams but
today it's not that day i couldn't
confirm unit 0203's position that's
actually correct
it's just me and all of a sudden we've
got this strange girl spouting nonsense
driving
because that would be fair
not just driving i take care of the
maintenance too you know of course
at any rate your comrades are safe the
only ones transferred here were you the
commander
thank you again for the gifted sub trip
i appreciate it
i did not do the ubisoft forward
reaction because of uh power issues
i tend to do it after this actually
of course this is in the future first
lieutenant rama rao was killed in action
before operation odessa even started
what's more
oh these two from different universes or
am i misunderstanding that because i'm
not paying enough attention
it happens when you stream uh like us
being part of the white white-faced
squadron something about erasures and
revisions to history the gundam barbatos
[Laughter]
it's very sweet
here to say enjoy what you do a lot i've
been playing this game though i've been
using the gun cannon ms for a long time
so i've been upgrading my other gun i'm
sorry
yeah it seems like it's been really
positively received by
my gun
which is awesome
thank you again for the gift itself
i should be paying more attention
[Music]
i feel like there's some sexual tension
going on here so i'm going to say these
two
i'm noticing something
hell yeah
[Music]
chosen a simulation of historical events
what in the world is this g universe
it's very cool like they did not need to
put this much
system isn't responding and uh i'm
basically just you again
my autonomous learning ai was nearly
written for the purposes of
communication with the two of you
so the admin system got you elected got
you and elected me a programmer
being in odessa we'll need some serious
firepower to tangle with that thing well
we did already tangle with it and
frankly i did very well
oh i missed someone oh yeah about the
gathering of gm
[Laughter]
okay cool i'm i'm curious to see how
much we can customize things
oh it looks like a lot
i'm just gonna get myself slightly more
comfortable
okay
thank you again for the gifted sub tram
to titan123 thank you so much i
appreciate it
soundtrack absolutely a magnet dude okay
change and upgrade your ms
being mobile suit for anyone who's not
familiar with franchise
let's try upgrading the zaku to type f
you can consume capital to upgrade your
ms
okay i see
20 000.
um
select
yeah i just want slightly more oh okay
lowering the upgrade level of previously
upgraded stats will earn you tune points
which you can then unlock to other stats
so the tune points cannot be carried
over to others
oh i would have done more than that
maybe i could
so we'll just keep improving the
firepower we have on hand going forward
raise ms analysis
thank you again tram what the heck
that's
thank you so much
it's kind of like a bioshock infinite
type
like there are tears in the reality i
think
you chose
i'll make it back
in the post-disaster history this is
like actually maybe a good intro to
gundam for some people
it's not
it's not
covering the usual cannon
but it's explaining parts of it
that's kind of cool
all right more banging soundtrack let's
that can be used to provide history dude
this is sick
so we remove puzzle pieces from the
wrong puzzles put them back in the right
puzzles and that'll fix things
foreign
um
[Music]
[Music]
pilot upgraded zaku type f i would like
to do it again but i think i probably
can't because i'm still in the tutorial
maybe i can
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you
phoenix gundam
this is a lot of unlocks
at least they make them cool
development completed
okay
tutorial
you probably could have done this all in
one menu i think
i do want to see if i can upgrade zaku
even more than i already had
or
there's my tune points capturing points
i don't know exactly how it works but
like i would like to
only buy two huh
let's do it
and then maybe another one of that that
seems good
i don't know what auto select would do
oh it wants me to do boost i don't want
to do boost
nah
you can stay where you are
skill set
equipping skills confers various effects
during missions use skills unlock as
your player level increases
[Music]
dashing side stepping and jumping
consume less boost oh that's cool okay
well we're gonna have to start with
speed stuff
for now
yeah this will unlock items
oh
i don't know if i want to do that
because what if i sell something i need
i don't think i want to do that let's
also just take a look at how multiplayer
works i'm not going to do it right now
okay simple it's just create a room
search for a room quick match
connect with other players online to
play missions cooperatively story scenes
will not be played but you can watch
them by the story scene viewer in the
library interesting so it just
takes you through
the combat and skips the story entirely
that's a really interesting approach to
that i guess that's in part because of
the way that i have it i'm just auto
playing the cutscenes by hitting f
um but people could get through them at
different paces so that would be kind of
difficult to design for so they've just
made it so that you would instead watch
the cutscenes later
that's cool
and then the library is where we have
in the library you can check tips replay
cut scenes and change left edit music
i don't know the name of the song that i
like
no this is too complicated i'm scared
play it uh
i don't remember how the song starts
actually
it's not that
that's the one
you know what i'm just gonna see if it's
on in spotify under that name because i
have looked before but like under the
japanese name
i love it so much it's such a good song
sasso
taru
shah
nope
doesn't look like it devastatingly maybe
someone someday will
uh get it on
spotify
cutscene replay this is actually really
cool
change music edit music
oh my god it's been so long since i
played a game that let you do that
you can add your own mp3s to play the
last time that i did that
was like
battlefield bad company 2 or vietnam
it would have been better for vietnam or
1942 not bad company on multiplayer i
was like in the helicopter listening to
like
fallout boy
that is awesome gta 3 yeah
dude that's so cool
wow
uh when do i think i'll get a puppy cam
i won't do that
uh that's too much effort
banjo alas is not here right now remove
music for that adjust music volume
let's see replay
i know that i don't need to do this by
the way i just kind of wanted to check
it all out because it's cool
very cool you also really don't use a
mouse for this game very much alright
mission let's do it
this is the one right
directory a directory b i think it's
this
you can change the difficulty for each
mission on easy you take less damage so
they're easier to clear this is
recommended for players who are new to
action games
easy missions will yield fewer expansion
parts it's a good idea fancy story to
unlock expansion plots what will happen
when you play all story missions on
normal i don't know you tell me
cool we don't want
all right baby
we doing it
let's go zaku
oh have a good night ours thanks for
hanging out
with
me
go back to operation right
also sorry the very bottom the screen's
cut off it's just because i have to play
in a windowed
that's uh wild
in the meantime let me give you a
rundown of your next mission stage the
history of gundam vomitus comes from
this is really neat
again
don't know how much it would appeal to
people on
i think it's cool
[Music]
that's that sarah palin get get get
getting hurt
foreign
the text resolution is not an issue for
me
it's just um
commencing missions
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh i swept to my second weapon and i
don't know how i still don't know how
that works
back to number one
they do feel very different for the
record
also i feel like zaku's like heavier and
maybe a little bit stronger like i'm
taking a lot less damage i think
i'm not blocking at all
hold for spin slash
that's kind of it
hold the launching attack yeah
galahorn soldier oh my special's ready i
want to see what it is
i love the way they scale stuff oh i can
knock buildings down
damn
sorry everybody y'all dead yeah the way
they scale stuff in the gundam games is
always really fun
because like those trees would be pretty
large look i'm huge dude
[Music]
i'm so big
beefy ass zaku
[Music]
breaking
[Music]
okay hang on let me use my special let
me use it everybody get away from me
i got [ __ ] today
i really messed that up and trying to
get the special out but still
this auto target's really good too
i like uninsighted
[Music]
gundam from the dynasty warriors gundam
games no way i also played those
i reviewed them
for an outlet that doesn't even exist
anymore actually
i got into gundam um from going to comic
book conventions as
we go
and uh
seeing them so i i built them before i
watched any of the any of the shows
what's this music okay
[Music]
i want to be you look how cool you are
i would like to be you
damn dude
i mean look
okay you know how like there's an ugly
sibling
and like a hot sibling
that's that's what's going on here and i
just i just feel like
it's not fair
i can't compete all right i guess at
least i'm nice
very uh very kind kind hearted
[Music]
strong heat source detected it's not
going to be like another boss fight
cities are cool
[Music]
all right let's go at least have healthy
from
like like maybe i should just stand back
and let these two hot dudes fight
look at you breaking buildings
clearly evil efferent
special special
[Music]
just a lot of speed and a lot of damage
leave me alone just for a second just a
second
oh
oh
oh my god the amount of explosions
hell yeah dude
the only problem i'm having with this is
because it's in japanese i'm not reading
the subtitles at all while in combat
but i don't think you can play it in
english
[Music]
this for everyone who's in the city
right now this must be the most epic
looking fight of all time
oh my gosh
there's like a free fireworks show out
here
this is crazy
and i'm doing very little to uh to work
with that crazy that's the cool guys
that's
that's these hot dudes not me
oh come on you're so close
get out of here
[Music]
[Music]
because i didn't know when i'd be able
to uh
this weekend i just didn't know what
time i'd be able to stream today because
of the power outages
and the heat
um i wanted to do by myself but uh
it all be uh lawrence would probably
really enjoy this actually it's probably
gonna be a fun thing to
love a good gun tank um to play with
other people i might say i might not
still want to
put a little gundam stream together
new ms has been developed gunter i do
like a gun tank
obviously it's split into three
different categories known as rolls
and this is a really good way to learn
about gundam it really is
like you're learning a lot of the
classic gundam
um
and they're basically like uh
if you haven't seen gundam before kind
of parodying
famous scenes
um
from the series which i don't know it's
like really good way to learn obviously
you'd learn what a gun tank is and what
a gun tank does and
the different kinds of gundam that there
are
and i think yeah having these different
classes is going to be fun for co-op as
well
has been added
who is char and how's he the best i
actually
maybe like three days ago
looked into
um how difficult it would be to do
char for halloween
and i was like
no i can't do this there's no way i
could boil
gun cannon looking hella cute out here
see it's like it's like an intro to
gundam because there are a lot of
different
series
as well like i have not seen all of them
i think um i haven't watched it yet but
a lot of people are really liking blood
orphan
but there's new content coming out soon
there's a new series and there's a movie
that's literally coming to theaters
[Music]
no i wish
collapse break
also yeah i finally remind if you put
the gun in command and chat that's why
you can check out the game
oh hang on no no let me go back to
upgrades
because we're probably going to use zaku
right or maybe i could do i don't want
to do gun tank
i could do gun cannon
uh now i'm crippled by choice i don't
know
i think i'm gonna do it let's check you
out
warning
[Music]
i'm using ranged a bit more
it's fine
then let's go upgrade
zapu
okay
[Music]
oh i didn't i didn't actually choose
your skills
[Music]
select a partner pilot for the mission
oh thank you chewie cow thank you so
much
okay
you choose up to two partner pilots part
of pilots cannot be the same pilot even
if the msa pilot is different
alliance effect passive automatically
activating affects a player
effects a player receives for ring
partner pilots along a mission are known
as alliance effects
such effects change based on partner
pilot roles if the rules differ the
number of effect types increases if the
unit rolls are the same the effects
stack
it's just like auto selection right now
this seems like a pretty good squad
alliance effects stack the higher
friendship is with a partner pilot ooh
it is kind of like a person however your
product pilot is shut down during the
mission you will lose the alliance
effect be mindful of your partner pilots
during battle
oh that's cool hyperdragon
so my university is offering an
internship and the internship is to help
out the school's esports team as a
commentator on social media aspects
that's cool that's awesome
okay when preparations are complete
select launch i'm fine with the
preparations as they are let's launch
baby
i'd love to go to venus let's roll let's
go
foreign
indispensable
a cute little american town
presumably
could be japanese
i just felt like the architecture looked
american or maybe european
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry i did that to the houses that was
me i apologize for that
i just keep i just and i just keep doing
it no you're an ally
outside town
head out through the streets boys we're
trying to keep people safe out here
[Music]
but i still don't know how to swap
between
the main and the two subs
i really should figure that out
new enemies
[Music]
oh no
music customization is such a cool and
like specific thing
interesting
thank you
i appreciate it
and welcome totally x cube xpb
raven lewis and we weigh over 9000 and
again oh my gosh thank you thank you
thank you thank you i appreciate it
thank you so much
well people are being super super extra
friendly tonight thank you it's a nice
uh welcome back after a little break
i think that right now um i have just
haven't set it up yet because obviously
i basically
just got home from spending time with
dad and then
um had all this
ridiculous power issues
um
i think we're gonna raise money to help
uh pakistan with the floods right now
will be the next charity that subscribe
to us
everything oh i have my special as well
and i didn't use it
like a dummy
i did go to alaska i love it there i
love it so much it was my second time
there and it was absolutely beautiful
oh no oh no oh no
strong heat sauce someone's bringing the
heat
damn you cool too everybody too cool
what the hell thank you genteel
now
it's interesting that everybody's kind
of aware of what's going on
wish i could pay more attention to it
the boss fight's a tough thought
again
thank you jensen
thank you thank you thank you thank you
um yeah snack captain it wasn't it
wasn't
oh my god oh god oh god i thought he was
going to go for someone else because
it's so far away
[Music]
okay
okay there is an emergency repairs
that's cool i wonder how many of those
you get probably not many right
oh that just brought me back up it
didn't give me more health
i don't know
i mean he's supposed to be dead
let's roll
uh any update on what podcast i am
ah thank you
jensen thank you for the prime stuff
yourself i appreciate it
get out of here
[Music]
foreign
beautiful
so yeah this is fun
um and i definitely think that
it's a good one for gundam fans
obviously um
the story is very cool but i also do
feel like
if you like this kind of game it's a
very specific style of game like
gameplay-wise
um but you don't like gundam this to me
in my opinion seems like a really good
way to actually get into gundam um and i
will like i said play pretty much every
kind of game that comes out and
i like most of them they're all pretty
different and all pretty good
um
and yeah you can check out the link in
the description or the link on twitch
to check out sd gun to battle alliance
it's a multiplayer gundam action rpg
allows players to battle stupid form sd
versions of mobile suits from the gundam
series which is why they look the way
they do which i love you can smash both
solo or with friends in thrilling
mechanized combat acquire new mobile
suits power them up and take them into
battle in various missions i definitely
think i'm gonna ask some friends if they
want to play it or stream it at some
point
um the story takes place in g universe a
world where gundam cannon twists and
turns in ways no one can predict
obviously which i'm very into to correct
the world's distorted history the player
leads a three-unit squadron consisting
of mobile suits and pilots from across
gundam history a true battle alliance
tackle missions with friends in
multiplayer launching a battle with two
partners to back you up multiplayer you
can play through the game with up to two
players and a three person team that
looks very easy to get into
and indulge in a wide array of mobile
suit weaponry to crash many foes with
control mobile suits portrayed with
realistic weathering that showcases them
as weapons of war as they tear across
the battlefield with dynamic animations
it's an action rpg that yeah they listed
as easy to play for everyone which i
would definitely agree deep single
player casual called multiplayer
yeah
it's cool i like it